he's uh espn baseball analyst he won the
cy young back in 1984 and boy does he
remind you all the time about that he's
rick
sutcliffe who joins us on loan for the
mothership
in uh on the call for the braves mets on
espn friday at 4 eastern
and uh oh you got some company there uh
rick who do you have
nano i thought you might want to meet an
oriole fan oh
that's the oriole fan we've been looking
for we
found the oriole fan and that's a great
hat
thank you what's going on buddy is this
uh your grandson
it is this is my grandson ryder um as
you know
the little league baseball got canceled
um so he's really excited about
opening day and he just wanted to say
hello and now he's off to camp for golf
school
all right see you ryder bye-bye
hey before we get started uh-oh uh-oh
yeah i need
i need our boy todd fritz to apologize
dan
to you yeah um yesterday he sent me a
text wanting to know if
opening day i was going to be on espn or
espn radio
dan this is 24 years with espn
um i don't do radio people that look
like you
and and luke zombie and other um
you know as you got older espn said hey
this sportscenter thing
uh it just doesn't look the same um so i
i
if todd will apologize i'll move on with
the show well wait a minute then you
have to apologize to me
because you just kind of called me ugly
and that i have a face for radio there
so todd you don't have to apologize i
feel like i do
no that has a rookie of the year i saw
your winner i know he took a shot at you
but he feels like i dissed him because i
just wanted to make sure for your notes
that it was an espn espn radio book
hey dan as i look at you i think about
one of the first interviews i did for
espn it was with mike piazza
and i'm sitting there and mike and i had
gotten close on the nike baseball trip
and he started ragging on me a little
bit and i said hey you better back off i
go
i broke my rule of thumb doing this
interview with you
and he goes what's your rule and i go i
don't normally interview people better
looking than me
and he goes who do you talk to
[Laughter]
yeah it's a short list of those guys
that you can't interview
yeah that got me off to a great start
when you came on sportscenter after an
opening day
um i had retired a bunch of my friends
had wanted to go to opening day and sit
in the bleachers at wrigley so we did
and that was the year ryan sandberg came
out of retirement
and you might remember this dan but we
go over to murphy's bleacher bar
after the game we're all partying and
everything and they holiday well hey
sportscenter starting off at wrigley
field
we run back in and there you are showing
the highlights sandberg hitting a double
in the gap
and your comment was two former cub
greats returned to wrigley
sandberg hitting the double and me with
a beer that was about that
uh you didn't get cheated across the
street from wrigley did you
do do you have did you ever pay a tab
at murphy's no i didn't ever do
and as you know um jim murphy gave me
the apartment upstairs
um then it all came about because
towards the end of 84
the cubs were going crazy after a game i
just wanted to go have a beer somewhere
and the clubhouse kid and i tried to
walk across the street
and the the city was so cub crazy at
that time that
i couldn't even get into the bar and the
following day jim murphy a
former chicago policeman was waiting on
me and he said please give me another
chance
and he moved all the liquor from up on
the second floor
uh who created a department he gave it
to me and as you remember
during the world series um you know a
couple of those parties were as good as
it gets
i saw or heard where mark grace took a
shot at you
during a diamondbacks uh broadcast uh
did you
did you get word of what your former
teammate had to say oh did i get word
um you know in the past it would have
been like a phone call but with
with this twitter thing now um it just
went craz
gracie we love him right yeah i mean
he's one of our favorites yeah
you know that he's like a son to me
yesterday
on the marquis sports network the new
cubs channel
somebody hit a long home run i haven't
seen it yet i've just heard
and gracie goes wow that reminds me of
some of them that sucked
[Laughter]
yeah who hit the deepest home run off of
you you know the longest probably
i mean it was during spring training but
there were two of them
one dave kingman hit one down in saint
pete in that ballpark
that was actually we don't know if it
was fair of foul it landed in the water
which is like maybe 600 feet away
the one that i remember as you say was
the shea stadium
back when it was shea kevin mcreynolds
hit a bomb
off the facing of the upper deck and the
ball hit so
hard that it bounced back and our
shortstop sean dunstan picked it up
and for some reason i'd never done this
but when he hit it i screamed i went
whoa
i couldn't believe it as i turned back
to look at home i thought he'd be
standing there watching it
no he was ha he was almost a second base
like it was
no big deal we're talking to rick
sudcliff he'll be on the call braves
mets on friday
at 4 eastern uh what's what's baseball
going to do with the blue jays here son
i i you know they're supposed to know
before the first pitch is thrown
um you would have thought dan and i know
you've probably talked about this that
that was the ideal situation to uh
social distance and
and and kind of keep people away with
the hotel that they have there
and everything going on um it's just a
it's a different day and age i i don't
know
the answer to that i will tell you this
um
i'm about as excited to do a baseball
game tomorrow maybe as i've ever been
um as you know i was blessed to be a
part of nine opening days
um this one's different but i tell you
what i
i go back a month ago to watching live
golf on tv
i i didn't tape it i watched it live all
four days i it was
it was so exciting to have something a
sporting event i didn't know the outcome
to
um i know that it's going to be
different i know that
you're not going to have a crowd the
noise when we did that summer camp game
on sunday with the
cubs in the white sox was was kind of
weird uh but i'm excited i'm thrilled
that baseball is trying to come back
yeah i'm i'm watching the broadcast and
uh the cubs and the white sox and
i i'm okay if there's i don't want crowd
noise pumped in
but if i mean if it's going to be then
fine what is the
what are espn's plans with throwing in
some crowd noise there
that's a great question um you know
we've got a big meeting in the morning
to go over a lot of that
um talking with a lot of the players
particularly with the cubs um
after the game on sunday there's a lot
of players that want that crowd noise
and i'll tell you
the main reason that that i think of dan
you know how
you know a pitcher will knock a guy down
and you know what that dugout's like
there'll be people chirping they'll be
hey
hey knock me down or whatever they might
say well you could say that in the past
because nobody could hear you
now they're gonna hear everything that
you say i i just think that
um you know the number one thing that
the crowd did
was it took that self-motivating factor
out of it
showing up every day at rigby field was
easy to go out there
and leave everything on the field i go
back to
before i got traded to the cubs when i
played for cleveland
there were a lot of times that literally
you could hear the guy banging on the
drum
you could hear the announcers and what
they were saying um
you know i know what it's like to play
in an empty stadium
and as you remember we've talked about
it um
playing for the the indians back in the
early 80s is where the movie major
league came from
uh there's a lot of truth to what goes
on in that story
you're not portrayed in that movie are
you
um you know what i'm not um um
i was not the wild thing um you know
mitch williams came along after that
i might have been that crafty old guy
that had vastly
did did you ever
did you ever load up a pitch i never
loaded up a pitch
um i will tell you this though you watch
these guys now
and a guy will hit a fly ball or hit a
ground ball and it'll come back and the
pitcher will look at it
and it'll have a scuff on it and they
throw it out
then i would still be pitching today
with a scuff on it you know what it's
like you put that stuff on this side
it's going to take off that way you do
it the other way
um i got a lot of outs on baseballs that
had scuffs on them
i never scuffed it but i knew what to do
when i had one what do you think of the
mookie bets deal with the dodgers
from the dodgers perspective is this is
this a great deal
it's a great deal um and it's a great
deal for a lot of reasons and the number
one for me
is being the type of person that mookie
is
that contagious joy that he brings to
the ballpark every night
he's one of those guys that doesn't have
to get a hit to be the mvp of the game
i never saw anybody play right field at
fenway park like like he's done
uh it doesn't matter where you put him
uh i applaud what andrew friedman has
done there
you know there's been a lot of guy he
didn't go out and get a lot of the other
guy
you know he could have had harper or
machado they had the money to go get
everybody
i think he found the perfect fit to fit
into that ball club and when you think
about how long he's going to be there
we could be talking about multiple
championships now you're going to do the
the braves mets but you're going to do
that from home
yes yeah just the communication and the
rapport
and i know you're working with people
you work with before but
just trying not to step on each other
during a broadcast has to be
pretty challenging i'll be honest with
you i i don't think we have that figured
out yet
um i i think that is going to be the
number one issue
um i have worked with luke chamber
forever
um we've never worked with chipper jones
before this was the first year that
chipper uh we'll be doing this
there will be some times i'm sure when
when we walk on each other and we'll
continue to try
to get better at that but i'll just give
you one situation you were listening we
did the white sox
cub game on sunday we had anthony rizzo
on for an inning
and stuff that chipper jones is going to
bring to our telecast that nobody else
has probably ever brought anthony rizzo
talking about
in miami going down sneaking down with
his dad to the third base uh
aside to yell larry larry
and then years later rizzo was playing
first base for the padres shipper gets a
single they're standing there
and rizzo's just looking at him laughing
and chipper like you know chipper's
telling the story rizzo's telling the
story
he's laughing and rizzo tells him why
he's on first base
what he and his dad used to do i mean
it's inside things like that that
i'm really excited about uh you know
being with chipper for
for this even though it's 60 games i'm
excited to have an opportunity to do
that
it's uh pretty amazing to see the the
bookshelf you know a lot of people come
on and uh they got all kinds of trophies
and uh but you're a minimalist you
you don't have any of your your trophies
there behind you do you
sut let me tell you something my pride
and joy right now are my two grandkids
i'd still rather have an mvp or a world
series title you know
you know you can look behind chipper
tomorrow and see all of that
i saw him on on sunday night it was like
oh chipper brought out the hardware
just to remind people yeah hall of famer
yeah it's a pretty decorated career
i would do that i can decorate although
first of all all of our all my stuff's
back in kansas city but the problem is
when
you know i put up that cy young
everybody always throws a date with that
and
when you hear 1984 a lot of kids just
shake their heads like what
wow you're old uh we'll be watching on
friday sun great to talk to you as
always
and uh our best to uh boog boogs and uh
and chipper you know what it's a
different year daniel it's a different
schedule we've got different rules but
as you know and you talk about it all
the time
it's the same goal you know everybody
wants to win that world series and i
love what david ross said the other
night
he said if they're giving out a ring i
want one so
thanks for having me anytime anything
anywhere you know that buddy thank you
bud that's uh rick sudcliffe
espn baseball analyst and cy young
winner uh also rookie of the year as
well